um obesity is a disease of
deficiency it's not a disease of excess
obesity is not a disease of excess
that's why nobody's been able to solve
the problem
because everybody views it as a disease
of excess it's a deficiency disease
the symptom of the deficiency disease
these special minerals
the minerals deficiencies cause a
special symptom called the munchies
and so instead of giving you these
minerals
medical doctors invented the snack food
industry
that's the treatment for the munchies
snack foods
next
so hell's kitchen is the book for
diabetes for obesity for the metabolic
syndrome we got plenty of those out
there
hell's kitchen you know we called it
hell's kitchen because a kitchen in your
home can be a place of heaven
or a place of hell depending on how you
cook
i mean you can kill somebody you can
purposely murder them all you got to do
is get them out with everything eat
fried foods fried foods for breakfast
lunch and dinner you'll walk
okay next
the paleo diet which is just essentially
meat and vegetables no grains but wait a
minute doctors say that whole grains are
good you mean the ones that live to be
56 okay go on
next
oh that tells the story next
oh yeah look at that next
look at that
next
okay
patrick jewell weighed a thousand
seventy two pounds
gave a stomach bypass
they put him on a calorie restricted
done he lost 462 pounds over a two year
period this is him leaving the hospital
to go home
when he got home he died
bam he just drops dead
because when you're obese fat is not the
disease fat is just a symptom of disease
just like when you have diabetes high
blood sugar is a symptom disease when
you have high blood pressure high blood
pressure the symptoms of disease being
overweight and obese is just the symptom
of the disease which is a mineral
deficiency the mineral deficiency will
still kill you
you all know somebody who's lost 50
pounds 100 francine did such a good job
she lost all that weight and then she
went and died
next
this gal here she had two guinness world
booker records
rosalie bradford she had two guinness
world book writer very famous lady
one number one her first guinness world
book record she was the heaviest woman
ever weighed she weighed 1200 pounds
officially by guinness book records you
went on two dates with rosalie you had a
ton and a quarter of fun
and then her second get his rulebook
record she officially lost 736 pounds
and then she
died
because
the doctors failed to understand that
the weight was not the problem was just
the symptom of the disease
okay are you getting it now
okay the mighty 90 will prevent you from
being overweight if you're overweight
you take the mighty nine and you throw
what we call the slender fx weight
management
program to it and the weight just goes
away helpful you stay on those things
you never gain the weight back you'll
add 25 to 50 healthful years your life
is that simple okay next
next next next
oh back up one
forty four percent of our kids under the
age of fifteen
of all races look like that today
that's because they are minerally
deficient
it has nothing to do with too many video
games
or too much television or too much
texting and all that kind of stuff is a
mineral deficiency disease
next
see everybody wants to think this is a
cause of obesity this is this the
symptom of the cause of obesity it's not
the cause of obesity it's the symptom of
the cause of it next
this young fellow here from south
carolina 14 years old weigh 555 pounds
they put the mother in jail and they
took him away from the mother they
should have put the pediatrician in jail
because she went to him every year
saying my kid's 200 pounds overweight my
kids 300 pounds overweight she kept
going to the pediatrician he said make
him exercise
he should have put the pediatrician in
jail not the mother okay next
loyola university in chicago came out in
august of 2009 and said exercise won't
help you lose weight in fact it makes
you hungrier because when you sweat from
exercising you're not losing just water
but a soup that contains all these
minerals and you lose all these minerals
you just get hungrier
okay
so now you take that money but you have
to take it appropriate for body weight
somebody who weighs 100 pounds will take
one third the amount of somebody who
takes 300 pounds because it goes one
dose per hundred pounds of body weight
okay it is by body weight you always
come to me and say well i've been taking
it for 14 months and nothing's happening
okay we weigh 200 pounds how much you
take why take a thimble full faithfully
every day okay well that won't work okay
okay